[Music]
the d4 square so a lot of times from
here you'll see you'll see people just
come up to 2 C 3 and here's a very very
crucial move that as you can see starts
the queenside attack and again there's
that many many variations so if you do
come across one and you want to you want
some analysis on it just let me know I'm
just going over a few of the things that
I see all the time when I play the
French defense and like to exploit but
usually I just bring my queen into the
action on b6 and this does a couple
things and you'll be surprised how often
people just don't know how to to play
very well against this it's adding
another attacker on to this this d4
square as you can see we've got we still
have our Bishop raining down on the the
c5 square but we have now 1 2 3 with our
our pawn Knight and Queen here on the d5
square and also we're attacking our
queen is attacking this B 2 square and
many many many times you may see you
know why develop his Bishop to let's say
e 2 and many times
you know you can develop let's say your
your night to age six which kind of
looks like a funny move and white
usually jumps on the bandwagon to to
take this because they're like well
we'll double up your your pawn on on h6
here but instead White's just going to
or excuse me blacks gonna just come down
to the B to square and even if black
doesn't develop his Knight to h6 a lot
of time white just feels that they need
to develop their their Bishop from c1
and we can just come down and capture on
the b2 square it's a brutal attack
obviously you can see if Knight moves
then the Queen can just capture on the
c3 square
checking the King and attacking the rook
and if he doesn't move then we can
simply just capture the rook so this
Queen here on b6 is just a very very
useful piece that you can use not only
to attack more on the d4 square but also
a possible attack on the B 2 square so
that is definitely something again I you
know I moved the knight to h6 obviously
we're not going to to move it to f6
since there's a pawn there and I hate to
move it already to the e7 square because
we have not developed our Bishop
obviously if we want to we could develop
our Bishop to maybe
e7 as kind of a waiting move we're
obviously not gonna bring it to d6 yet
so logically it would make sense to
bring it to h6 that's why why I did that
so that is just something to keep an eye
on obviously the center will eventually
get broken up and then in this case
obviously we somehow as you can see this
this Bishop here is still a weakness for
us so eventually when we start our
on the queenside we will want to free up
this bishop on the LightSquared but
already you can tell we have a queen
side attack coming
and eventually black or excuse me why
it's going to start a King side attack
to probably develop their their bishop
sometime maybe after they've blocked our
Queen side both Pete both sides are
going to Castle kingside it's just going
to happen if white castles Queen side
he's got an attack coming that's not
good
and for the most part as you can see
it's a closed up center here so there's
probably not gonna be fan shadow bit of
Bishops the the bishops aren't going to
be on g2 and g7 so just something also
to to keep in mind if you do see that
just exploit that that weakness that you
see from your opponent so we're going to
go back to the beginning and look at a
different option that you may see and
that is simply if white doesn't go where
we just talked about so we'll go over
the French defense
efore e6 and see d4 d5 as we talked
about and here instead of moving forward
we're just gonna do a simple Knight to
b3 or excuse me c3 and this you actually
will see quite often I normally see
Knight to c3 or just moving the pawn
forward to to e5 here either one doesn't
matter from here we're actually going to
play a little bit differently
the the knight here is attacking our our
pawn here and this pawn here so we can't
we can't quite capture instead we're
just gonna bring our knight into the
action putting added pressure on here so
now we have our pawn attacking and our
not attacking for the most part why it's
not going to continue to jeopardize his
King side by moving something like f3
right away
instead whites now normally going to
push up and move that night out of the
way and so from here as you can see it's
kind of a similar situation that we had
earlier with the pawns on d4 and d5 and
here we can just easily move our knight
to the d7 square and nothing has really
changed we haven't blocked in our our
dark square bishop our queen our queen
wasn't coming to the d7 square anyway so
that doesn't you know hinder him at all
and our light square bishop is not
anymore blocked in than he was before a
lot of people would look at this move
and be like oh man you know you've
blocked in pieces but if you really look
at it and analyze it we haven't blocked
any pieces that weren't blocked in
before so we can continue on with our
with our normal gameplay we just have an
extra piece developed once we play our
dark square Bishop here then our knight
can our excuse me our King can castle
right away we don't have to develop our
night our Knight doesn't have to come to
this silly h6 Square so I actually
prefer a lot of times you'll see this c3
development I don't mind that at all
because I actually like having my my
night here on d7 anyway adds an extra
attacker to this c5 score along with the
e5 square so if you do see the c3 from
the night you know don't worry it's
actually not a bad thing eventually as
we said before black wants to develop
his pawn to the c5 square adding more
pressure he still has the bishop on f8
as a defender and now he has the
defender from the knight on b7 so hope
this helped there's a lot a lot of
different variations but I feel this is
actually a very very sound and good
defense that I play almost exclusively
against the e4 pawn opening from white
and really like it obviously I mix in
something like this Sicilian but hope
the ideas
really helped you guys out please
subscribe to the videos I've got a lot
more coming out but that really helps
out if you guys subscribe leave comments
if you have any questions or any videos
you want to see your questions about
this video or any others just leave me a
little note let me know what you think
so hope you guys enjoyed and I'll see
you all next video thanks